новий календарний рік був на вашому для
всієї України навіть для вас
не і системи перед нами поставлена
звучання серйозні соціальні таси
встигли опуці
а також за грози пов'язані з пандемією у
спини між сильними державною владою
organic месії у вас обладнання
освітлені наука вти нам у дає сивий
важко через забезпечує стабільне
функціонування системи та зміт ​​і те й
безперервний розвиток усічення 2020
пішого руку міністерством спину знову
купцями то педагогами розрубаний у з
відкинуто нову редакцію базового
компонента дошкільне свити якийсь з
державним стандартам дошкільної квіти
основу базового компонента дашки та
святі та baume то обидва скроні та
компетентності які мають бути на but i
тривалу дошкільного віку і до
умів
за цим циклом потенції мають but in з
формулою одним із основних
компетентності школі риф та новачки
логічного і математичного і слави то
наукова і розумінні природи
приватних технологій ми програму ще в
у кого технічніше математично
інженерний професії став знову
популярними хочу популярність потрібно
розвивати і дивимося про нього знаю школі сам
цьому серб не 2020 руку і поруч була у
хвалу та концепцію розвитку з темпу
свити
реалізації річкою перетворюється на 2020
самого руку
виріс не 2020 руку за три джені
державний стандарт базові середнього
почти на основі якова
розрубаю на топову середню програму
тарас по чату розробка модельних
початкових за ініціативи
the pitt патронатом перша леді України
сьогодні активно проводиться реформа
шкільного харчування
і надане йшла свій петрін курсу space
ти про т
для успішної реалізації ті та реформи
необхідно об'єм на низу син багатих
міністерств та відомств і ми моєму з
рубає і від же в нас є спинам це
виросте і ви вистачай здорових
хіба на них щось освітлених громадян
україни закручуємо президента україни
розрубано
то презентований план модернізації
професій на профі дуже технічні
святі які вижити в основі стратегії
розвитку системі прав ти його почти
вид пам'ятному одним із ключових завдань
u2020 пішому роті сфері професіонал
проксі на технічні свитий з відкидання
стратегії розвитку профі сильні
розлиті на період до 23 уроку
з 2020 уроку вперше за круту 2 малу
праву в ступа таємної тільки діти стем
годин упакованого криму до місця
севастополя а йди ти там годинника
окуповано донбас у колеги та
у зав'язку зміною кількостю світло
них центрів збив на загальних ось і 2 до
12 тисяч сімсот 5 10 місяців у
дев'ятнадцятому уроки так як ось
зупинила вище 2600 місяців до робіт ще
до прийому cifs там вартового купава на
території заз міцну процедуру в
польше зізналася все
закладають святі з
сфері управління міністерства оборони
здоров'я і 14 університетів
заходиться у сфері управління
міністерства культури до 3 університетів
веб міністерство внутрішніх справ скрип
не 2020 руку запитувала
у крему урядова ховальна лінія
ступників тим часом упакованих
територій вони приймають на константу ват
цей факт ще на зображуючі на різанині
ви слави та думки в соціальних міражах за
сабах масової інформації ми все-таки
змогли гідно протити алгоритм
роботи на період дистанцій на його почту
спина з читером і бочками і
їздового ніж її почту ми сперечався з звуком
лаком дикий нас правді став для нас
доступним броком знайшли х то діджитале
ції його почету в Україні та за прийняті
сен-симону прямо ми розуміємо
розум з партнерами продовжуємо працювати
на вч а йому в 4 у створі розуму нові уроки
платформи запас причому а по карате
інтернетом і сну ходом віконце на
технічніше за чоловіка влади ще до Польщі
червових завдань міністерство квіти та
податки сам і тому міністерство святі
науки спинного змін цифри українська
стату розвитку свити
так романську спилку з вікторію розрубав
це презентували 11 грудня 2020 року руку
національну електронну платформу з
українська школа онлайн
який він звернув я ягоду дату до
змішаного то дистанційного навчання
учинив 5 11 класі
станом
19 лютого на платформі кільки
зареєстрованих учасників більше не
134 тисячі диких
більше не що тисяч врахувавши 27000 в чотири
з половиною тисяч сухачів 18 мільйонів
взаємодій платформу вид бачити щур
лікарі більше не зі 103 крайон кольору я до
чому не свердловини в них тріскати трубу
і ви рішення за нашою спиною активною
долі послуга не вас міченого а
інновації на вас мистецтво наші спини -
або ми ми зможемо у досі ти spinomed та
ви славну поляку кожному з вас за
Тясмин і на краще ще вибивається в
україні сковорода вас